a gente está falando sobre a
transformação de uma pátria que a gente
ama que a gente tem esperança nela mas
que cada via fica pior
e aí quando nasce um negócio chamado ted
dex educação
a gente vê que é uma grande ferramenta
de mudança de transformação mas não
existe revolução não existe a evolução
se a gente contar nossa história
todos os outros dois palestrantes que
passaram por aqui contar um pouco da sua
história também os que virão depois de
mim também contaram um pouco de sua
história porque a história se mistura
com a sua própria história
então eu vou antes de começar a contar a
minha história eu quero dizer que esse
meu papo de hoje através da educação
tenha pretensão muito pequena de tentar
falar sobre dois assuntos apenas dois
assuntos o primeiro com as maiores
consequências do engajamento cívico no
país
quais são as maiores consequências de um
baixo engajamento cívico no país ea
segunda é como que a gente faz para
construir um país com um estado menor
lembrando que não dá para falar sobre
estado menor na vida de tantas pessoas
que o estado nunca chegou a gente
precisa falar que o estado pode diminuir
quando o estado visitar a casa de todo
mundo que o estado visitou mas se eu
queria bater um papo sobre esses dois
assuntos durante essa tarde de hoje
mas antes de começar a falar sobre essas
duas histórias eu queria falar sobre uma
história
essa moça linda e maravilhosa chamada
isadora nós estamos juntos há 23 anos
entre namoro noivado e casamento
esse amor essa dor essa luta essa
confusão nos deu duas meninas
sophia de 9 anos e essa menina metida
com que com a música o que acho que já
dá pra ver que ela se acha chama-se nina
nós somos classe média da cidade de
recife moramos no bairro de casa forte
eu me formei em administração de
empresas mba em gestão empresarial
fiz um curso de planejamento estratégico
que era um vendedor vendia tá gelo sem e
sem ter transformado em gelo ainda na
água mas eu pra entregar eu precisava
ter um curso de planejamento estratégico
até que num belo momento me convidar
para fazer um mestrado em teologia
imagina eu fui fazer o mestrado em
teologia então essa minha formação e
toda a dormir deve o pai do irmão são
dentistas
a gente aqui na cidade do recife a gente
botou a clínica de ortodontia e começou
a levar para todo o brasil
uma técnica de fazer com que as pessoas
da base da pirâmide pudesse ter acesso a
um tratamento que era caro chamador todo
dia então eu era o senhor desse grupo
meu pai meu irmão cuidavam da operação
ea gente queria que não apenas à af a
mãe a dona da casa tivesse acesso à
tecnologia mas sim a moça que cuidava da
aba da casa pudesse também tem uma
filosofia eu fiz isso de 96 até 2010 96
até 2010
só que em 2010 eu e minha esposa nós
somos cristãos e na sala da minha casa
rolava um grupo de estudo bíblico
só que na segunda feira específica além
de rolar rolou o grupo de estudo bíblico
e uma reunião de condomínio no meu
prédio eu desci para a reunião de
condomínio tem aqui é fã de reunião de
condomínio levanta a mão favor muitas
mãos graças a deus por isso então eu
cheguei na reunião de condomínio que
estava abrindo a porta do salão de festa
era meu vizinho de porta que sabia que
tudo que aconteceu na minha casa nas
segundas feiras porque a minha porta
fica aberta a dele também
aí eu assim que foi entrando o volante
fabinho que está fazendo aquilo que eu
vim pra reunião de condomínio mas hoje
tem o seu grupo estudo bíblico eu
disse-o sabe sei que é que eu digo que
acontece na sua casa
eu digo diga eu disse vocês lêem a
bíblia vocês cantam músicas estranhas
vocês olham por todo mundo inclusive
fume e vocês comem bastante eu disse seu
pedro quando chegou em casa e disse
nunca nunca e eu disse porque eu nunca
falei casa porque vocês são os
extraterrestres
vocês são bento vocês estão falando
sobre o céu e não soube transformar a
terra
eu nunca ouvi vocês falarem sobre
justiça e cidadania promoção do bem
comum
vocês são o grupo religioso não quero
participar disso
eu fiquei olhando pra ele eu vou dar uma
usar na casa desse cara agora porque ele
está se metendo a minha convicção de
festa até o display de seu pedro taques
não falo eu quero dar dois exemplos e
materializam o que eu estou dizendo
a primeira coisa eu nunca vi ninguém do
seu grupo de cerca a comida que sobrou
porteiro que não jogou
e a segunda coisa venha cá e pegou e me
levou para a rua a rua de trás do prédio
chama-se rua tapacurá
ele disse tá vendo todos os carros hoje
16 em cima da calçada em cima da árvore
fechando a porta do prédio e assim é
então toda a tua casa então toda vez eu
era por meia hora você sumir daqui
porque vocês são o caos e não são o céu
aí eu fui sair o constrangido entrei na
minha sala estava aquele pedacinho do
que eu sou meu vizinho tinha me dito um
comer cachorro-quente ou tocando o outro
nem na bíblia já começa a reunião eu
entrei na sala esse pessoal
a reunião acabou como acabou vai começar
senão acabou não mas acabou não vai
começar acabou e minha mulher no meio da
soja pra mim deve ter pensado assim esse
cara não foi perdido com o nome dele foi
por culpa do descarrego
todo mundo saiu à porta bateu eu caí no
choro profundo que estava gastando minha
vida e nada de nada
todo mundo a igreja me achava o super
homem falava em absolutamente tudo
batizado e quando casais mas o meu
vizinho de porta me desculpe o termo eu
não posso falar
não me admirava
e eu acho que quando o vizinho de porta
não lhe admiro e alguém que admira tem
alguma coisa muito errada terça feira de
manhã diz isadora chama o povo por favor
de novo você tá louco o povo etapa foram
outras que chama o povo dessa feira
audiência a record casa lotada
agora imagina o vizinho de porta vendo a
galera chegar na minha casa na terça
feira ele deve pensar nesse caso o que
se vai ter uma reunião segunda e terça
quando o pessoal entrou setor de pessoal
a gente tem um pai bastante de fora pra
falar pra vocês e eu disse o senhor é
macho vim aqui agora ela é tão macho que
nem a camisa ele colocou estava sem
camisa retrô
ele é pelo dele parece um uso
todo mundo via ele vai ficar olhando os
cabelos do pt ele
ele soltou [ __ ] neta da sala queria
levantar para matar ele metade da etapa
é crente e ao dizer mas creio que a
gente aquela confusão
ele saiu da sala deixou rolar eu peguei
meu computador coloquei no centro da
sala
mandei e disse esse pessoal era final de
2010 o estado de pernambuco debaixo
d'água na cidade de barreiros e palmares
sofriam eu peguei e mail escreveu e meio
disse a gente mandava todos nossos
amigos vão pedir dinheiro o que eu tenho
de maluco minha mulher tem de sair tinha
então colocar minha conta bancária pouco
a minha conta bancária conjunta com
minha mulher nesse meio seria o caos pra
ela desceu a minha mulher vai deixar de
dar conta então alguém dá conta o cara
de uma conta poupança dele que estava
parada
então imagina que sair recebeu um e-mail
de um cara que não sabia quem era com a
conta poupança de outro cara grande
planejamento estratégico
uma semana nós arrecadamos 96 mil reais
virou sete caminhões de colchões como
barreiros e palmares entregar já estamos
entregando o último os portões até que
bateu nas minhas costas disse fábio aqui
tem uma creche chamado áureo cine água
bateu na lateral dela ela tombou ea
gente tava lá entregando cocho
entregando coxim
eu dou pra voltar pra minha vida e eu
olho para esse sim aí e aí vamos ajudar
a amiga vim aqui pra colchões
o cara disse assim passou o fábio tem
gente que gosta do sos criança não
nunca mais eu sair disso a creche foi
reformada
as ações começaram a explodir
esse negócio viralizou agora tinha um
gatinho em cima do alvo e chama o povo
novo jeito para tirar vou me entregar a
cadeira de rodas vamos furar poço no
sertão
vamos adotar uma creche vamos adotar o
asilo este foi um negócio tão gigante no
ano passado a gente teve a oportunidade
de contar essa história do vaticano o
próprio francisco
a história daqui isso aqui de um cara
maluco e você tem conta para pagar que
tem sogra que tem tudo você tem
[Aplausos]
as palmas não me separei sogra não é
possível qualquer um normal fazer coisas
de ter alguma forma que pode transformar
eu comecei a sair jornais e revistas em
papos internacionais
eu comecei a falar sobre esse negócio 24
horas em todo lugar do brasil e eu não
sabia mais o que eu era porque todo
mundo dizia pra mim que a educação ea
mudar o brasil educação vai mudar o
brasil é educação do brasil o brasil
tenha educação minha filha de educação
será que o que está faltando para a
classe média não é engajamento cívico
será que o que a gente está falando pra
classe média não é outro tipo de
educação e esse negócio foi crescendo
crescendo crescendo eu acho que vocês já
viram algumas das nossas ações
nós invadimos cidade entregando rosas
nós somos uma das maiores frente de
mobilização e engajamento para
catástrofes nós juntamos arquitetos e
territórios para reformar abrigos
creches e toda vez que isso acontece o
arquiteto diz assim
agora eu sei porque eu me tornei
arquiteto é aquele jovem que está
estudando direito mas não sabe que ele
tem que ser um procurador um advogado um
procurador ou promotor o sede de justiça
toda vez que a gente se engaja que a
gente coloca nossos talentos para render
a gente descobre propósitos esse de
mission missão porque a gente veio pra
onde a gente vai
o novo jeito se tornou gigante a gente
faz ações como vox por exemplo só que o
novo jeito e crescendo crescendo
crescendo não falar uma palavra de
inglês
eu tenho nesse momento inveja de dois
tipos de ceira os magrinhos que estou
gordo e os segunda turma que fala inglês
que está cheio de oportunidade eu não
falo
o cara me liga e diz assim eu e eu moro
se amanhã tem o toque koff eu estou indo
cheguei lá o cara me entregou um cartão
do departamento de estado americano
quando ele me entregou ele sabe de toda
a minha vida
eu disse o avançado onde please um
século
fui para o banheiro e liguei pra minha
mulher que já não aguentava mais
nessa trajetória durante sete vezes ela
quase que me consegui me colocar pra
fora de casa
eu disse isadora o fbi está aqui fora
que me prender
esse cara me levaram para os estados
unidos eu passei 60 dias no programa de
imersão sendo eles que quando a gente e
poderá líderes sociais esses líderes
sociais de alguma forma pode transformar
sua pátria de alguma forma esse líder
que podem influenciar seu território
eu conheci várias coisas mas eu conheci
duas coisas que mudaram minha vida
a primeira no 13º dia estava na
califórnia
eu conversei com dois caras que são
desenvolvidos programas de educação e de
saúde fora do governo e ao passar isaac
o governo suíço havia ganho em escala e
ter transformado a vida de centenas de
milhares de pessoas vão ser dois caras
falaram virei para eles assim qual a
profissão de vocês o que é que vocês são
porque eu sou igual a vocês eles
disseram eu sou empreendedor social era
clara na califórnia liguei pra casa
meu amor oi ela já falava sempre comigo
oi eu sei o que eu sou
ela disse ela já estava de saco cheio de
mim eles já que você está na califórnia
eu tenho certeza que você descobriu
peguei e bateu o telefone na minha cara
e eu disse não eu sou empreendedor
social e eu voltei para o brasil para
tentar fazer programas de políticas
públicas para que as pessoas possam se
engajar no finalzinho da viagem eu
conheci a agência nacional de
voluntariado que fiquem rosto de cada
dez americanos 8,5 deles têm engajamento
cívico 10 8,5
esse engajamento cívico ele não é global
ele é territorial
esse papo de que vamos mudar o brasil me
tira vamos mudar a rua a esquina a praça
o bairro à cidade
nosso prédio nossa família nossa igreja
nossa empresa nosso colégio o que a
gente está fazendo hoje aqui é mudar o
território pessoas vão sair daqui para
transformar esse território pessoas vão
sair daqui com muito mais do que uma
mensagem de inspiração o ferramentas e
com um sopro de alguns podem dizer é o
sopro dos do espírito para mudarem essa
cidade
depois que voltei começamos a criar
programas e nasceu na cidade do recife
o primeiro programa de voluntariado de
política pública do brasil
chama se transforma recife uma
plataforma que quem precisa de vagas de
trabalho voluntário oferta e quem quer
ocupar
opa e colocamos na rua de verde na nossa
cidade nós temos impostômetro é marcador
por morte de arma de fogo acidente de
trânsito e temos um voluntário metro e
marca as horas de trabalho voluntário de
toda a cidade
o transforma hoje está em nove cidades
do brasil petrópolis campinas cuiabá vão
chegando em campina grande em salvador
estamos criando a plataforma de todo
mundo que quer ajudar pode se preocupar
a través de vagas de trabalho voluntário
a gente dizendo para pessoas da melhor
idade que elas têm que colaborar com o
brasil elas podem ajudar
não é justo um projeto social precisar
de advogado de médicos e professores não
ter um de procurar não é justo um jovem
estudante passa a vida toda sua vida
acadêmica na universidade pública e
quando se torna o profissional só presta
serviço para quem quer quem pode pagar
não é justo a gente precisa mudar essa
história
o transforma ganhou no finalzinho de
2016 um prêmio da onu como um dos
principais programas de política pública
do brasil
aí a gente disse vamos criar uma
incubadora e aceleradora como criar uma
escola de cidadania
ela se chama porto social fica na ilha
do leite
nós estamos ensinando sobre casamento e
cívicos o pertencimento sobre
transformação do território temos nesse
momento 85 projetos incubados
essa é a área beneficiamos 200 mil
pessoas
temos cursos rápidos cursos contínuos
neste momento está no porto social até
ontem 21 21 empreendedores sociais de
todo o brasil estão vindo para recife
para aprender o que a gente tá fazendo
aqui
esses são projetos que estão incubadas
no curto projeto aurora projeto aonde
amar que cuida de famílias vítimas da
microcefalia a gente está fomentando e
acelerando a primeira orquestra
filarmônica de cegos e surdos do brasil
vai nascer aqui na cidade do recife
mas eu queria concluir dizendo que tem
um novo bicho aí na na vida da gente
chamado empreendedor social e são
pessoas que querem passar izar com
gestões públicas com gestores públicos e
podem se de alguma forma transformar o
brasil eu quero finalizar contando uma
história dessa senhora ela tem 62 anos e
num belo dia nós temos um programa de
doação de cadeiras de rodas
o líder do programa de cadeira de rodas
me ligou e se pode ver que entregasse a
cadeira de rodas e eu fui lá pra
comunidade do papelão lá na comunidade
do papelão quando entrei no barraco
segurando a cadeira de rodas
eu perguntei para ela quais são seus
sonhos ela estava deitada numa cama
porta pegaram a porta transformaram numa
cama e entra a costela dele o braço dela
e uma maçaneta estará 2015 na minha
cidade na sua cidade disse
vai ser um show e da senhora que mora
numa cama porta há quantos anos as dez
anos diz qual o seu nome disse carmem
eu disse quantos anos a senhora tem 62
quais são seus sonhos
ela disse o primeiro ganhou a cadeira de
rodas eu estava aqui
ela estava ali eu disse dona carminha
cadeira pra que esse meu filho eu sou
ceca
a diabetes além de chegar e ainda tirou
o lençol
as duas pernas dela haviam sido
computadas 2015 na minha cidade a sua
cidade morando em cima de uma cama porta
cega duas pernas amputadas
eu disse quais são seus sonhos eu tenho
dois anos qual o primeiro ganhar a
cadeira de rodas eu tô há dez anos
separam no uma cadeira de rodas básica
custa das parcelas de r$39 é esse sonho
dela
a gente pegou ela colocou em cima da
cadeira de rodas ao bater a foto ela
sorria ela chorava e eu disse donna
karan e qual seu segundo sonho ela disse
tomar sorvete da eteo nunca também
mas o vento nunca tomei imagina que a
gente ainda vive na sociedade de gente
com sorvete do livro do abraço do
carinho da educação da saúde
a gente colocou nas redes sociais da
carne é comandado papelão primeiro sonho
é a cadeira de rodas postou uma foto
segundo os oito mas o vp da e ajuda 18
minutos eu conhecia a menina mais de
cabelo da minha vida
a menina chegou na comunidade segura no
pote de sorvete da e gritando chegou
chegou chegou chegou chegou a pagar o
sorvete de a menina ter uma colherada
colocou na boca da dona carmem dá cá me
disse assim sorrido do lado de fora o
céu bater na pele os vizinhos saíram
porque achava que na casa havia morrido
já não acaba disse assim o reino do bem
chegou o reino do b chegou hoje à tarde
aqui visitou seu coração visitou sua
vida e através dessa tarde e você sai
para espalhar o rei do bem porque você
tiver onde você tocar e com quem você
chegar muito obrigado deus abençoe
[Aplausos]